four and two feels great for the
panthers yeah right right especially
because they lost two games four days
apart to start the season they lost to
the rams they lost to the buccaneers
what the hell's wrong with cam newton oh
we know what's wrong he's got a mid-foot
sprain that he had hidden from the team
and the team acted like they didn't know
what was going on since then kyle allen
four starts
four wins we saw the great win in you
sound like y'all from london yes right i
like it and uh
um i don't even know what that reference
is i just i'm used to you saying it i
know it's forgetting sarah marshall but
i don't i don't i didn't see it or i
don't know you need to see that movie
it's very funny so anyway uh what was i
talking about oh yeah the carolina
panthers
cam newton's gonna be healthy right
right what do you do and it's funny
because you've already got people who
are like oh well you're not saying the
same thing about drew brees
well drew brees the all-time passing
yardage leader when he's healthy he's
back playing again kyle allen is the
future cam newton is the we don't know
what right now for the carolina panthers
yes he was the mvp four years ago but
he's either injured or we're worried
about the next injury with cam newton it
never stops and this is a way for them
to break that cycle and just go with a
guy who can run the offense who you
don't have this constant fear that we're
doing too much or are we not doing
enough are we holding them back are we
putting them at risk and i think it's a
liberating feeling for the panthers to
not have that that constant question i
hear you right of cam newton's proper
use hovering over them or can he
practice and be healthy and all those
things too yeah and i i don't i mean
it's i think it's a pretty serious
injury i really do right and
um if you're the panthers you kind of
want to let this ride out i i hear you
you know i i will stand by what i've
been saying i still think the the
carolina panthers will be at their best
with a healthy cam newton but right now
kyle allen's gonna make it hard on them
to make that move right away until like
cam newton's a hundred and ten percent
uh
and you know yes i mean he's 4-0 as a
starter now they got a bye week you know
i don't want to throw cam newton out
there in the next game they got to play
at san francisco 49ers and that group
you know maybe you know maybe that's the
game where okay we put kyle allen there
one more time we see if he is for real
and maybe that's the game you start to
draw the line on you know oh gosh you
know we were kind of steamrolled by that
that 49ers defense maybe that'll show
them i think that'll be a huge point for
them it's either going to show them man
kyle allen's for real and we got to ride
this out because we beat the san
francisco 49ers or even if they lost
close i think you still have to ride
with them but if they like feel like oh
we got overwhelmed and kyle allen was
overwhelmed by their team a little bit
maybe that finally does give them the
confidence to go back to cam newton i
think as i've said before that when camp
newton is healthy and you're ready to go
back to him when this kyle allen thing
cools off even when it cools off
you can go back to cam newton and you
can just do cam newton things and not
worry about him getting injured because
if he gets injured yeah you've got
another guy right fine there yeah here's
the other thing too here's the other
reason why i think there's a presumption
that uh we're going to see drew brees
and a question about whether we're going
to see cam newton we see drew brees
every game right we see drew brees doing
the thumb flexes getting ready to go and
he's there and he's helping teddy
bridgewater yeah cam newton's been out
of sight out of mind yeah and and the
team says well you know we don't want
him to be standing on that foot well
they have benches yeah he could be on
the bench he could have the tablet he
could be helping kyle allen and he's
just not around and i think that's part
of the
out of sight out of mind off we go
and you know cam newton's got one year
left after this season on his contract
and i always thought this was an up or
out year for cam newton anyways yeah
extension he's gonna be gone right right
now it feels like he's gonna be gone
yeah and you have to ask
at some level
does he want to be there is he thinking
at this stage in my career
maybe my best play
is to go somewhere else i don't know
where he'd want to go yeah right but
maybe my best play is to go somewhere
else yeah you know maybe um he certainly
has made his mark on the city he's still
a phenomenal phenomenal football player
uh and hey there are teams that don't
don't let injured players be around and
do that stuff like new england you're
not gonna see any injured players on the
sideline during that you know i don't
know what cam newton's reason is i don't
know if i necessarily believe what
they're saying either way i think it's
smart
by cam newton north carolina who's not
there it can be a distraction with him
there i mean gosh let's just talk about
the guys that are there that are playing
football i think the last three weeks we
would have watched these games
carolina's playing and there would have
been like 10 minutes devoted to cam
newton sitting on the sidelines you know
and what are they going to do and cam
and you know you don't have to hear that
or the carolina panthers don't have to
deal with it
so i understand them kind of keeping him
out of the spotlight when this goes on
but kyle allen again not doing things
where i go oh wow this is so amazing
just really playing the position uh pure
he's just taking what's there to be had
every now and then he'll make a throw
where you go oh that was pretty good
throw good for kyle allen and of course
they can run the ball and they got a
defense and you know this is why we
thought they would be in the nfc
playhouse right i mean we knew this team
was good they really blew two early
season games because of cam newton and
his health status and you know now
they're going to be in a fight to make
the playoffs i've got two teams i'm
intrigued by that i'm thinking about i'm
projecting into the future seeing cam
newton in their universe yeah are you
ready yeah i want to hear the chargers
okay that's a good one chargers yeah
you're trying to get entertainment
right new stadium right cam newton
and you know it just feels like this
philip rivers thing he's going to be one
of the aging quarterbacks maybe the only
one who doesn't get to leave on his own
term i think he's done after this year
based on what we've seen so far this
season and also hey 10 buccaneers put
them in bruce arians if they don't keep
jameis winston and you don't want me
carolina i'll show you carolina i've got
the brett favre set reverse mccoy i'm
going to stay in the division and i'm
going to stick it to you every chance
it's interesting thoughts certainly i i
mean that is a very interesting thought
really i haven't thought about this at
all i'm just trying to look at if
there's any other teams that jump out to
me nobody else in the nfc i don't see
but i like where you're at there and
then you know there is going to be teams
like the cincinnati bengals that i think
it'll be going on i'm not going to want
to play for them i wouldn't think so
they'll draft somebody you know that's
the thing you can get where they are is
to force them to come to you yeah right
tennessee titans they go where do they
go that's sexy enough yeah maybe not
either i hear you i mean it's not
happening in cleveland indy oakland yeah
so i mean i think you might have hit the
teams really
on the head there there where it could
be a possibility
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports